d'ailleurs les festivals sont de retour
ou un petit peu partout au pays et au
québec après deux ans d'annulation du à
la pandémie et les retombées sont très
importants pour plusieurs villes du
québec ont fait le point avec michel
archambault il est professeur émérite en
tourisme à l'école des sciences de la
gestion fondateur de la chaire de
tourisme transat de l'uqam bonsoir
monsieur archambault
bonsoir madame on se demande si on
amorce cette saison avec une position de
force parce que dans les deux dernières
années événements annulés d'autres
tenues dans des conditions qui rendaient
la rentabilité presque impossible
puisque les festivals ont été fragilisés
par les deux dernières années
vous êtes très bien effectivement ça a
été ça a été de 1,10 milliard hors
carrément carrément
bloqué jusqu'à un certain point de vue
là ce que je peux appeler la la
croissance des festivals surtout par
l'absence de visiteurs étrangers et on
rappelle que des visiteurs étrangers
peuvent représenter jusqu'à 50% des
dépenses on l'a vu récemment par exemple
avec le retour de la formule 1 à
montréal où vous avez pour cet événement
lors du de près des deux tiers des
visites d'un qui proviennent de
l'extérieur du québec et on a eu des
taux d'occupation des hôtels qui frise l
heure de 100% donc à ce moment là il est
évident que les deux dernières années
ont été des années très
douloureuse pour l'industrie du tourisme
et en particulier pour les festivals qui
jeu qui je le rappelle représentent des
dépenses pour le québec environ deux
milliards par année oui mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment un retour tout à fait à
la normale ou à la suite de ces deux
années difficiles les coffres sont moins
garni est ce qu'on peut faire les choses
comme on le faisait avant ou c'est un
peu
on s'est un peu ajustées parce que les
finances sont moins solides
mais je je dirais qu'on est en période
de transition c'est une c'est quand même
un retour cette année d'un retour avec
peut-être l'absence
moindre avec des visiteurs de
l'extérieur du québec moindre la
majorité provenant de l'ontario et
quelques-uns des états unis mais je
rappelle que un visiteur sur une visite
sur sept étaient dus de par des
personnes qui étaient qui habitait à
l'extérieur du québec et encore une fois
ces personnes là même s'ils ne
représentent que 14% par exemple pour
les grands événements internationaux
qui sont regroupés sous le rémi en trop
et il représente plus de 55 % des
dépenses donc on n'est pas on est
parvenu évidemment à cette étape là mais
il en demeure pas moins qu on sent un
renouveau
s'est quelque peu de l'oxygène qui est
insufflée dans la majorité des festivals
et des festivals sont aussi un parpaing
pour la gaspésie le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean que québec qui
actuellement vi le festival d'été de
québec et montréal où se termine sur ce
point le festival du jazz et qui va être
suivi par d'autres grands festival nuits
d'afrique à traiter vous avez évoqué
monsieur archambault l'importance des
touristes étrangers du fait qu'ils
étaient moins nombreux ils reviennent et
dépensent plus que les québécois on se
demande avec les le chaos dans les
aéroports l'aco vide qui semble
tranquillement reprendre de l'ampleur on
est officiellement dans un septième
vague à un voile qui plane sur le bon
déroulement des festivals mais je dirais
que ce sont des freins ce sont des
des incidents on a vu le bordel dans
l'ensemble des aréopages pas simplement
montréal macarons et même en amérique du
nord il est évident que la meilleure
façon d'atteindre montréal pour des
américains du nord-est et de l'ontario
ça demeure évidemment de l'automobile
qui peut-être que peut-être le meilleur
moyen de 32 d'atteindre la destination
mais il est évident que le fait que les
incidents qu'on a connu dans les
aéroport fait en sorte que ça pue
restreint l'envi de voyager à l'heure
actuelle surtout avec la perte de
bagages oui on sent que c'est tout un
cas clair la bonne nouvelle pour les
festivals à tout le moins ce qui a
encore du soutien financier le
gouvernement annoncer un soutien de 85
millions aux festivals et aux événements
touristiques sur trois ans est ce que le
gouvernement en fait assez pour faire
survivre et mieux que ça à faire vivre
l'industrie
écouter
les différents niveaux de gouvernement
les contributions gouvernementales
représentait avant la pandémie environ
17% du budget d'opération de l'ensemble
des festivals selon sur selon le type de
festival dans certains cas ça peut aller
jusqu'à 40 50 % le gouvernement a
augmenté la a contribué quand même pour
palier aux inconvénients de la pandémie
en augmentant sa contribution et ça a
été bien reçu par l'ensemble des
festivals je pense et ça a permis de
sauver pas simplement dans les grands
pour les grands festivals mais ça le
permis de sauver ou au moins de rendre
moins fragilisé l'ensemble de plus de
plus petits festivals qu'on pense par
exemple au festival de la chanson je
dois vous arrêter parce que je sais
monsieur archambault que votre liste
serait longue y en a beaucoup et au
grand bonheur des festivaliers mais on
doit s'arrêter si je vous remercie
beaucoup pour vos explications
ou clézio mains pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit
oh